America is acting like a parent with a
kid that's out of control
and you just let them run Wow you
already talked to him you already put
them in timeout and now it's time to get
a whooping you know we've already told
them they need to stop we already people
have been arrested if you keep doing
this you're gonna have to be met with
force speaking of a democratic run
situation last time we did this you were
here in my studio in my home here in Los
Angeles so right now I was just scanning
Twitter before I started chatting with
you and I can see activists antiph on
black lives matter activists talking
about which neighborhoods to go to
depending on whether they're they have
immigrants there or it's more heavily
black or more heavily white or the rest
of it
what should law enforcement be doing
right now I mean we know as 7:00 o'clock
rolls around and it gets darker even if
there's a curfew we know what's gonna
most likely happen tonight it's gonna be
the same thing that happened last night
what should they be do I mean what if
you're an officer or you're the you're
the head of the LAPD what should you be
doing right now it's time to take a
strong stance I said this on the news
earlier or it was a couple days ago that
America is acting like a parent with a
kid that's out of control and you just
let him run Wow you already talked to
him you already put him in timeout and
now it's time to get a whuppin you know
we've already told them if they need to
stop we already people have been
arrested if you keep doing this you're
gonna have to be met with force and if I
was the head of LAPD or any chief in any
one of these cities you have to be met
with force you're not going to damage
property people are paying tax dollars
for police to protect property and
protect life you come out here and you
try to burn down buildings you're gonna
give me a tree force and all the way
from minimal force taser pepper ball a
beanbag gun all the way to deadly force
if we do that force continuum I
guarantee you people will not be
stealing from Louie Vuitton and going
through the city ravaging the city
turning up homeless counts it will not
have
the police department has to be strong
you keep taking a weak stance they're
gonna take advantage of us is part of
the fear there that the police officers
or the administrators whoever the mayor
whoever it is they know that if they
take that strong let's say tonight they
were like art we're taking the stronger
stance tonight they know that causes a
spike that then causes the media to go
more crazy that then instigates a new
wave of it that that in many ways their
acquiescence is exactly what has led to
this this situation that now seems like
violence is the only thing that's gonna
end it yeah and I get that I understand
I mean we we had to have these
conversations at the University of
Arizona when I was a police in Tucson
because after they win the Final Four
and they want to protest and burn down
the city so we I've had these
conversations before but like I said I
keep liking it to a child if you keep
just pandering and saying oh I don't
want to spank in a day it's just gonna
make you more upset you got it you got
to be strong first and they'll react to
it there's gonna be some fallout there
may be a couple people that lose their
lives but at some point we have to take
a strong stance as a country as a
law-enforcement agency so we can be
respected people are gonna hate police
no matter what and this is one problem
that I have
sometimes with Trump and sometimes I
have with it with the Republican
administration is that stop worrying
about what people who hate you gonna are
gonna think about you they're gonna hate
you if you do nothing they're gonna hate
you if you take a strong stance they're
gonna hate you if you're right so just
do what's right and don't worry about
what the naysayers say did you happen to
catch Van Jones his comment in the last
couple of days where he said what
America has to fear more is the white
Hillary voting liberals did you catch
that by chance yeah I saw I saw a clip
of that which is one of the many things
he said so yeah so what do you make of
just the general concept there of that
much of this is sort of guilty white
liberals and now I know we're not
identity politics guys so of course I'm
not I'm not condoning everything he's
saying and I don't think you can lump
white people together the same way you
can't love black people together but but
the general idea let's remove color even
that it's sort of the guilty liberals
who in many ways feed the fed feed the
fire that then
ends up destroying black communities
yeah it's too guilty liberals that are
white and black because you have all
these black leaves pushing the same
agenda you have white leaders push on
the same agenda I mean listen the
liberal mindset and I'm honestly wonder
if it's a mental problem like if it's a
mental illness I'm being honest like why
is it reasonable to not be rational I
just I just don't understand forties 50
something genders everybody can do
whatever they want to do live whatever
life you want to live they claim that
the police are the evil ones but then
they don't want you to have a rifle or
have a gun to protect yourself I mean
they want to let criminals go and
bombard the city and do whatever they
want to do but if you allow abiding
citizens you should be punished they
want you to wear masks but then they
then they allow people to not social
distance because it's for the right
cause these are people who are illogical
amongst us and it's destroying our
country in these same mentally adverse
individuals are the ones that have
socialism communism the countries are
destroyed over and it's not just a color
it's a mentality because there's black
and white people that are doing the same
thing and there's black and white people
who are on the side of saying let's wake
up to this man let's stop hating each
other let's stop the the division let's
stop lying about racism in this country
let's stop talking about slavery and
talking about Jim Crow let's start
thinking logically and working together
as brothers and sisters in this country
to make it better but these liberal
people I don't know what it is man is it
I don't know if it's just that they want
power more than they care about people
and they're willing to say and do
whatever to get to that point honestly I
can tell you what I think it is which I
think most of it's just lazy thinking
they don't want to think about these
issues hard so they think if they kind
of feel that something sort of right
they think that that that makes it right
I've seen so many examples of this in
the last couple days where you can get
these people to flip the positions that
they held three months ago so there was
a there was a tweet that i retweeted
from somebody who
he's in a he's in an LA whatsapp group
like a community whatsapp group and the
woman who set up the community was
originally set up so that they could get
guns out of their community and now
she's in there screaming in all caps how
can we get you know security guards with
guns to be watching our streets and it's
like well you guys take whatever
position you need to take on any given
moment so when you call it sort of like
a mental condition I mean I always call
it it's like a mind virus you can if
they don't have a they don't have a
principled stand they just have oh I I
kind of feel like something and then and
that's a scary place to be right I mean
you can get people to do almost anything
yeah I mean the saying goes that if you
don't stand for something you'll fall
for anything if you are living off the
emotions your emotions change you know
and they become hypocritical and there
are people in our society that operate
with facts I don't know if it's from
birth I don't know if it you're just
more susceptible to think with facts and
and be logical I don't know what it is
Dave and I'm afraid that if we don't
start calling this stuff out the good
people are the people who are
strong-minded we're gonna be overrun by
these lunatics because they are willing
to go all the way out and some of us who
are rational and logical we're not I'm
not willing to go out and protest and
burn down buildings for because I don't
like the Cova 19 response that's my last
resort
that's after I've gone to the
legislature that's after I've complained
to the governor that's after I have been
peaceful for a significant amount of
time I'm not willing to go and burn down
places and kill people
over over emotions and in these are
things that I believe the strong man has
to stand up for and white people and I
don't want I don't I mean and play
identity politics but we need to start
keeping it 100 why people need to start
being bolder and more brave and standing
up against the lies against white the
white privilege police brutality all
white people are bad you're born with
silver spoons you you you are oppressing
the black man listen systemic oppression
systemic injustice it's clear racism
like how are you saying that every judge
is somehow races against black people
that that is asinine to even make a
statement like that when you when you
don't have any variables you cannot say
that this judge in this county with this
prosecutor with this juror
you know this jury pool convicted a
white man this way and then turn around
and convicted a black man this way
they're not making a one-to-one
comparison they're talking about
somebody in LA then I took my somebody
in Georgia with total different laws
total different judges different
demographics different different
backgrounds different history different
mitigating and aggravating circumstances
it I just I just don't get it in and I'm
getting frustrated and upset because we
need to start standing up just like
Donald Trump I'm sick and tired of
watching the left send everybody to
prison there's indictments every time I
turn around for people on the right
they're condemning them that column
erases on TV but then you see Don Lemon
calling people like myself sellouts and
Negros and nothing happens with him you
see Hillary Clinton clearly breaking the
law she should be in prison for what she
did nothing happens to them all of this
investigation of pizza and all kind of
other stuff and know what nothing
happens to them it's because we just sit
on the sidelines we're gonna have to
start stepping up and fighting back if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell